Ben, we're talking about Ben. Prolific speaker on the C++ speaker track, algorithm expert, polyglot. Anthelmint is interesting for another reason. I have long considered it the sort of most, recorded on April 19th, 2022. My name is Connor, and today with my co-host Bryce, we talk to algorithm expert Ben Dean about C++ algorithms. Well, let's do this right off the bat. We're hopping, well, before we hop into things, we'll get... I know, I have a feeling I know what Connor's about to do. They're never going to sponsor us, Connor. They're never going to sponsor us.
Ben，我们在谈论 Ben。C++ 演讲领域的杰出讲师、算法专家、多语言专家。Anthelmint 之所以有趣还有另一个原因。我长期以来一直认为它算是最……录制于 2022 年 4 月 19 日。我是康纳，今天我和我的联合主持人布莱斯一起，与算法专家本·迪恩（Ben Dean）讨论 C++ 算法。好吧，我们一开始就这么做吧。我们正要……嗯，在我们切入正题之前，我们会……我知道，我有一种预感，我知道康纳要做什么。他们永远不会赞助我们，康纳。他们永远不会赞助我们。
Did you hear Netflix down 20% after hours today so maybe maybe maybe nvidia will replace netflix as the n in uh in fame i feel like that acronym is now increasingly irrelevant with with the players in the market you know i feel like i throw a lot of shade at netflix on this podcast for absolutely no reason and if anybody who works who works at netflix is listening to this podcast for absolutely no reason. If anybody who works at Netflix is listening to this podcast, I really have no problem with you. It sounds like a great company, but I will continue to throw shade. All right, Connor, do your thing. Our thing is that we're terrible.
你听说奈飞（Netflix）盘后下跌 20% 了吗？所以也许、也许、也许英伟达会取代奈飞成为 FANG 中的 N 呢？我觉得这个缩写现在和市场上的主力军越来越无关了。你知道，我觉得在这个播客里我对奈飞进行了无缘无故的大肆吐槽，而如果任何在奈飞工作的人在听这个播客的话，我真的对你们没有任何意见。听起来像是一家伟大的公司，但我会继续吐槽。好了，康纳，做你该做的事。我们的事就是我们很糟糕。
Well, we're good. I think we're decent podcast co-hosts, but we do a terrible job of introducing our guests as demonstrated by our last recording with guests when we had patrice and jason i thought this was a bubbly i thought you were gonna go do a bubbly oh no we well we've got the brand new bubbly flavor it's well so of course how is bubbly because uh what's the name of the other one? I can't remember. Perrier? No, no.
好吧，我们很好。我认为我们是不错的播客联合主持人，但我们在介绍嘉宾方面做得非常糟糕，正如我们上次有嘉宾的录记录所证明的那样，当时我们有帕特里斯（Patrice）和杰森（Jason）。我以为这是一个气泡水……我以为你要去拿气泡水。哦，不，我们……嗯，我们有了全新的气泡水口味。这很好，所以当然，Bubbly（气泡水品牌）怎么样？因为……另一个叫什么名字来着？我不记得了。巴黎水（Perrier）？不，不。
Uh-huh. No. They even, they spell bubbly wrong. Oh gosh. I had one today and I can't even remember the name. San Pellegrino? No, it's a flavor. It's, it's.
呃-哈。不。他们甚至把 Bubbly 拼错了。哦天哪。我今天喝了一罐，甚至记不清名字了。圣培露（San Pellegrino）？不，这是一种口味。它是、它是……
La Croix? La Croix, that's the one. Oh, see, that's big down in the States. It's not really that big up here in Canada. But I've just discovered Spindrift, which is, which is like La Croix, but nice. I have to say, they have compromised. It's not zero calories.
La Croix？La Croix，就是那个。哦，你看，在美国那边它很火。在加拿大这边其实没那么火。但我刚刚发现了 Spindrift（果汁气泡水），它就像 La Croix，但是很好喝。我必须说，它们做出了妥协。它不是零卡路里的。
It's a whole five calories a can. La Croix, if you want to sponsor us, we will make Ben come back and apologize. I'm not a big La Croix drinker, but I do drink La Croix. But I've recently discovered Spindrift. We tolerate it. We tolerate it. Everyone tolerates La Croix drinker, but I do drink LaCroix, but I've recently discovered Spindrift. We tolerate it. We tolerate it. Everybody tolerates LaCroix. Yeah, exactly.
每罐整整有五大卡路里。La Croix，如果你想赞助我们，我们会让 Ben 回来道歉。我不是 La Croix 的大酒客，但我确实喝 La Croix。但我最近发现了 Spindrift。我们容忍它。我们容忍它。每个人都容忍 La Croix 的饮用者，但我确实喝 La Croix，但我最近发现了 Spindrift。我们容忍它。我们容忍它。每个人都容忍 La Croix。是的，没错。
What's the difference? See, well, I just want to talk. This is meta because we are literally proving what we're bad at. We're bad at introducing our guests. We got two seconds into introducing Ben, and then Bryce was like, weren't you going to talk about bubbly? And then whatever percentage of attention deficit disorder I have, I was like, no, but let to talk about bubbly? And then whatever percentage of like attention deficit disorder I have, I was like, no, but let me tell you. And now we're talking anyways, let's finish this topic.
有什么区别？看，嗯，我只是想聊聊。这很元（meta），因为我们实际上在证明我们不擅长什么。我们不擅长介绍我们的嘉宾。我们在介绍 Ben 时只用了两秒钟，然后 Bryce 就说：“你不是要谈论 Bubbly 吗？”然后不管我有百分之多少的注意力缺陷多动障碍，我都说：“不，但让我来谈谈 Bubbly吧？”然后不管我有百分之多少的注意力缺陷多动障碍，我都说：“不，但让我告诉你。”现在我们无论如何都在聊天了，让我们完成这个话题吧。
Spindrift, is that what it's called? Spindrift? Spindrift is like La Croix, except they've compromised, as I say, very, very slightly on the calories for much nicer flavor, in my opinion. Interesting. You know, my go-to drink is vitamin water zero i literally have a fridge full of vitamin water zero at all times it's like i don't drink water i just isn't isn't that like the crypto isn't that like the crypto of drinks it's just a big scam it's i'm
Spindrift，是叫这个名字吗？Spindrift？Spindrift 就像 La Croix，除了正如我所说，它们为了更好的风味在卡路里上做了非常非常微小的妥协，依我看。有意思。你知道，我的首选饮料是零度维他命水（Vitaminwater Zero）。我 literalmente（字面意思）的冰箱里随时都塞满了零度维他命水。就像我不喝水一样，我只……这难道不是就像加密货币一样吗？这难道不是就像饮料里的加密货币吗？这只是一场大骗局。
it tastes too good to have zero calories i'm sure something in it is going to kill me but i am addicted it's fair enough literally my my mother was here the last week visiting me and she's like i want a glass of water there's no water in this apartment can i just have some regular water wait don't you isn't is the tap water in new york not drinkable it, but I don't know. All of the women in my life want cold water, and my apartment does not have it. All right. Well, any of the companies, aforementioned companies,
它好喝得不像是零卡路里的。我确信里面有什么东西会害死我，但我已经上瘾了。这倒也是。真的，我母亲上周来拜访我，她说：“我想喝杯水。这公寓里没有水吗？我能喝点普通的水吗？”等等，你不是……纽约的自来水不能喝吗？但是，我不知道。我生命中的所有女性都想要冰水，而我的公寓里没有。好吧。好吧，上述任何公司，
including Sapsucker, which might be the spin drift of Canada, which I think it has like 20 calories or 15 calories a can, but's like it takes like recycled i don't know syrup or something and um i don't know honestly it's got it's something it comes something from a tree something from a tree's in it i don't want syrup that somebody else has already had i i don't think that's i don't think that's what it is but it's like I think there's a process of making syrup, and then there's some like, you know, like in an oil, what do they call that stuff in an oil plant or oil refinery, and then there's like a pool where all the bad stuff goes.
包括 Sapsucker（枫树汁苏打水），它可能是加拿大的 Spindrift，我想它大概有一二十卡路里一罐，但就像是用回收的……我不知道，糖浆之类的东西做的，嗯……老实说，它里面有某种东西，某种来自树上的东西。我不要别人已经喝过的糖浆。我不认为……我不认为那是这样的。但它就像……我想有一个制作糖浆的过程，然后有一些像……你知道的，就像在石油厂或炼油厂里一样，然后有一个池子，所有不好的东西都流到那里。
It's called like a something off. Oh, that makes more sense. That makes more sense. I think Ben actually knew the name of it. What is it called? You mean like a sump? Like that just collects the runoff kind of? Yeah, yeah, runoff. That's what i was thinking of that's the word um my my older sister as an engineer would have definitely uh had it right away and shannon she's um yeah she's in calgary
它被称为某种径流（runoff）。哦，那说得通。那说得通。我想 Ben 实际上知道它的名字。它叫什么？你是说像集水坑（sump）吗？就像那种只收集径流的东西？对，对，径流。那就是我想的词。嗯……我大姐作为一名工程师，绝对会立刻知道，Shannon，她嗯……她现在在卡尔加里，
now left left me all alone in toronto but uh i think it's basically the runoff of like maple syrup which is still good for stuff but not syrup and so this drink company could be the spindrift equivalent speaking of syrup i was going to say the current syrup i have in my fridge i just made pancakes and i noticed on the bottle and this is going to offend everyone right on the bottle it says product of usa and canada oh that is that is wrong that is wrong i there is one good why there is one good maple tree product from canada and that's maple butter specifically the type of maple butter that jf's brother brings me every time i see him and yes this is a coded way of me telling J.F. to tell his brother to continue to bring me maple butter.
把我一个人留在多伦多。但嗯，我觉得它基本上就是枫糖浆的径流，这对某些东西来说仍然有用，但不是糖浆，所以这家饮料公司可能是 Spindrift 的同类产品。说到糖浆，我本来想说，我冰箱里目前的糖浆……我刚做了煎饼，我注意到瓶子上——这会冒犯所有人——瓶子上写着“美国和加拿大产品”。哦，那是错的，那是错的。加拿大有一个好的枫树产品，那就是枫脂（maple butter），特别是 JF 的兄弟每次我见到他时带给我的那种枫脂。是的，这是我用密码告诉 JF 告诉他的兄弟继续给我带枫脂的方式。
You just said like two episodes ago that he doesn't have time to listen to this. You just ripped on him for like 10 minutes. Somebody else will listen to this, like Connor or somebody, and will then tell J.F., and then J.F. will tell his brother. I got a system.
你就在大概两集前还说他没时间听这个。你刚刚吐槽了他大约 10 分钟。其他人会听到这个，比如 Connor 或其他人，然后会告诉 JF，然后 JF 会告诉他的兄弟。我有一套系统。
But no, real maple syrup is made in made in vermont it is it is a product of vermont america all right 10 minutes later today our guest i think other than sean parent you are the second ever returning guest to the podcast unless if my memory's failing me we've definitely and for the listener we cut every time we record with someone into like two or three episodes so if you're thinking what are you we record with someone into like two or three episodes. So if you're thinking, what are you talking about? Everyone's been on two or three times. False.
但说真的，真正的枫糖浆是在佛蒙特州制作的。它是佛蒙特州、美国的产品。好了，10 分钟后……今天我们的嘉宾，我想除了肖恩·帕伦特（Sean Parent）之外，你是本播客有史以来第二位回归的嘉宾，除非我的记忆力衰退了。我们绝对……而且对于听众来说，我们把与某人的每次录音都剪辑成两到三集，所以如果你在想，“你们在说什么？每个人都来过两到三遍。”错的。
Everyone's been on once except for Sean Parent. And then we cut that up into 30 to 35, 40 minute episodes. So Ben, the last time you were on was during the virtual C++ Now of 2020, I think. No, it was 2021. I was gonna say this almost this time last year this podcast did not exist at the time of yeah c++ now 2020 would have happened you're on your 74th week or whatever it is yeah let's well let's be honest we've all lost track of time and uh in in this virtual new world that we live in um but wait bryce don't say anything we were we were like we were we were almost there we were almost introducing him so if you if you're in the c++ community you've probably heard of ben uh he's a prolific talk
除了 Sean Parent 之外，每个人都只来过一次。然后我们把它剪成 30 到 35、40 分钟的节目。所以 Ben，你上次来是在 2020 年虚拟的 C++ Now 会议期间，我想。不，那是 2021 年。我正要说几乎就是去年的这个时候。在……是的，2020 年 C++ Now 发生的时候，这个播客还不存在。你已经进入第 74 周还是什么的了。是的，好吧，老实说，我们都对时间失去了概念。在我们生活的这个虚拟新世界里，嗯……但是等等，Bryce，别说话。我们当时……我们当时……我们快要到了，我们快要介绍他了。所以如果你在 C++ 社区，你可能听说过 Ben。他是一位高产的演讲……
speaker winner of many best speaker awards at c++ now one of the main talk speaker i'm a talk speaker well you know honestly folks i should read a talk speaker. Well, you know, honestly, folks, I should read a sentence that I wrote the other day on Discord. There were so many skipped words and grammar mistakes. Anyways, so he's a prolific speaker with dudes. What's the actual? Just speaker? I think that's the word you're asking for.
演讲者，在 C++ Now 上获得过多次最佳演讲者奖。主要的演讲者……我是个演讲者。好吧，老实说，各位，我应该读一下我前几天在 Discord 上写的一句话。里面有那么多跳过去的单词和语法错误。总之，他是一位高产的演讲者……伙计们，到底是什么？只是演讲者？我想这就是你要找的词。
I've got to be honest. I just got back from running 18K very quickly at Run Club. So I'm a little bit, and I'm in like a 2,500 calorie deficit right now. Did you shower? I did, yeah. And I showered right before. Anyways, Ben, we're talking about Ben. Prolific speaker on the C++ speaker track.
说实话，我刚刚从跑步俱乐部的 18 公里快跑中回来。所以我有点……我现在的热量赤字大约有 2500 卡路里。你洗澡了吗？洗了，是的。而且我刚刚洗过。不管怎样，Ben，我们在谈论 Ben。C++ 演讲领域的杰出讲师。
Algorithm expert, polyglot. If you've listened to his CppCast episode, I think you started off by going through the plethora of languages that you have studied at one point or used. Likely. Jason always asks about history and that sort of thing. So, yeah. Yes, Ben is a fellow, uh, program language, historian, uh, enthusiast. What do you, what is it? Is it a book of file or, uh, some, someone you have a library of file, bibliofile. You are really bad at words today, Connor. This is going to be a rough takeoff. And the reason Ben's on today and Ben's one of my favorite speakers. What let's list off a couple of your talks. What's the, I'm not even gonna remember any of the names of them, declarative.
算法专家，多语言专家。如果你听过他的 CppCast 节目，我想你是从列举你在某个时期学习过或使用过的众多语言开始的。很可能。Jason 总是询问历史和诸如此类的事情。所以，是的。是的，Ben 是一位同仁、嗯，编程语言、历史学家、爱好者。你是什么，这是什么？是书迷（bibliofile）还是……某个你拥有文件库的人？Connor，你今天词汇量真的很差。这将是一个艰难的起飞。这就是今天请 Ben 来以及 Ben 成为我最喜欢的演讲者之一的原因。让我们列举一下你的几个演讲。什么是……我甚至记不住它们的名字，declarative……
Yeah, one was called easy to use, hard to misuse declarative style in C++. Yes, fantastic. Ben, what's your favorite talk that you've ever given? That's probably a hard question to answer. That's a hard one, but I suspect like several speakers, I feel like I've given the same talk in different guises several times
是的，其中一个叫“C++ 中易用、防误用的声明式风格”（Easy to use, hard to misuse declarative style in C++）。是的，太棒了。Ben，你做过的最喜欢的演讲是什么？这可能是一个很难回答的问题。这是一个很难的问题，但我猜和几个演讲者一样，我觉得我在不同的幌子下好几次做过同一个演讲，
or variations on a theme. There are two styles of talks that I really think about. The easy style, which is, here's a thing I did, here's the code, here's a C++ feature, here's how to think about it, explain it, et cetera, right? The easy style of talk to me is like, you have code, you explain it. The harder style, the more, but the more rewarding style is the sort of more philosophical style. Can be illustrated with code, of course, but that style is more of the kind of declarative style talk.
或者是同一个主题的变体。我真正考虑过两种风格的演讲。轻松的风格，就是，“这是一个我做过的事情，这是代码，这是一个 C++ 特性，这是思考它的方式，解释它，等等，”对吧？对我来说，轻松的风格就像是，你有代码，你解释它。更难的风格，更……但更有回报的风格是那种更具哲学色彩的风格。当然可以用代码来说明，但这种风格更偏向于声明式风格的演讲。
So I like both styles. Like I like the philosophical style, but the easier one to put together is definitely like, here's the code, here's how it works style. Easy to use. Yeah, easy to use, hard to misuse. You had the other one too recently. I think it was at CppCon, which was the,
所以我两种风格都喜欢。就像我喜欢哲学风格一样，但更容易拼凑在一起的绝对是“这是代码，这是它的工作原理”这种风格。易用。是的，易用，防误用。你最近还有另一个。我想它是在 CppCon 上，那是……
or no, that was at C++ Now as well. Identifying monoids. Yeah. And also the talk that I don't think ever gets mentioned enough. And it definitely, well, it was at Cpp con. So it didn't quote unquote, win any awards, which is maybe why some of the other ones get more buzz. Even though obviously, they're, they're really good is the stood accumulate an algorithm empire. I think that talk is fantastic, because of sort of just the exercise of I think you use the word sort of perversely, like you're using the algorithms in ways they shouldn't be used. Yes. And bending them as an exercise to really see like what they're capable of.
或者不，那也是在 C++ Now 上。识别幺半群（Identifying monoids）。是的。还有那个我认为从来没有得到足够提及的演讲。它绝对……嗯，它是在 CppCon 上。所以它没有“所谓地”赢得任何奖项，这也许就是为什么其他一些演讲能获得更多关注的原因。尽管显然，它们真的很好，那就是 `std::accumulate`：一个算法帝国（The `std::accumulate` An Algorithm Empire）。我认为这个演讲太棒了，因为那种练习，我想你用了“反常的”（perversely）这个词，就像你在以不应该使用的方式使用算法。是的。把它们当作一种练习来真正看看它们有什能力。
And a bunch of the things you point out is like, don't do this stuff. But the exercise of doing this with the, you know, where you give a little summary of the talk. Well, that talk, like the talk that Jason and I did, Constance for all the things, it's kind of interesting to look back and see that that talk like the talk that jason and i did context for all the things it's kind of interesting to look back and see that that talk is of its time right and to look back and be like wow that was like you say that was just an exercise in making accumulate implement different algorithms and it was a sort of a thought experiment if you like i mean it was an actual code experiment but in a sense it's a
你指出的一堆事情是：不要这样做。但用……你知道的，你对演讲做了个小结，来做这个练习。好吧，那个演讲，就像 Jason 和我做的那个“万物皆常量”（Consts for all the things）一样，回过头来看看会很有趣，你会发现那个演讲……就像 Jason 和我做的“万物皆常量”一样，回过头来看看会很有趣，你会发现那个演讲带有时代的局限性，对吧？回过头来会想，哇，就像你说的，那只是一次让 accumulate 实现不同算法的练习，如果你愿意的话，它有点像个思想实验——我的意思是它是一个实际的代码实验，但在某种意义上它是一个思想实验，但回过头来看很有趣，你会发现，你知道，它现在有点带时代的局限性了，而且我像我们所有人一样，回过头来看我自己的代码，我会想，你知道我在想什么吗？我不应该那样做——从某种意义上说，对于那个演讲来说这没问题，因为整件事都建立在“这真的很有趣，是一个很好的思考方式，但千万不要写这样的代码”的基础之上。那个演讲中的核心名言，我把它剪辑到了我的一些演讲中，那就是在某个时刻，你经历了一个练习，看看你可以用 `std::accumulate` 或其某种柏拉图式的等价物实际实现多少种算法。对，对。是的，所以是 90 种里有 77 种，对吧？对，而且我想我们在 14 种里有 90 种算法，诸如此类。Connor，刚才是……就像……你刚刚掉线了一秒钟，一秒钟。Connor 现在正在经历未定义行为。是的，回到我们身边，Connor。你还好吗？大家能听到我说话吗？是的，我们整个过程中都能听到你说话。我猜听众也能听到你说话。就在我说到 90 种算法中有 77 种可以用 `accumulate` 实现时，这个女人在我的耳机里开始说话，说：“您的耳机电量不足，请重新充电，即将关机。”好吧，你看，我觉得这可能不是你第一次收到耳机电量低的警告，因为……这是真的。那是真的。那个女人今天早些时候说过什么，我忽略了她。嗯……是的，你本该听的。好了，Ben，回到你这里。你刚才要说你的一个演讲……我的一个演讲产生了不少影响，人们似乎还记得，或者至少，可以说是会议演讲者这个高雅小圈子之外的人——我在现实生活中以及在我曾经呆过的游戏行业里与之交谈的人——他们真的很喜欢我做的那个“有效使用类型”（Using types effectively）的演讲。
thought experiment but interesting but interesting to look back at and see you know it's kind of of its time now and i look like all of us i look back at my own code and i think you know what was i thinking i shouldn't have done that like there are better ways to do that in a sense for that talk it's fine because the whole thing is predicated on just this is really interesting and a good way to think about it but don't ever write this code sort of thing the key quote from that talk that i've sort of clipped into a couple of my talks is that at a certain point you go through the exercise of seeing how many algorithms you can actually implement using std accumulate or some the sort of platonic equivalent of still accumulate yeah yeah and yes so 77 of
思想实验，但很有趣，回过头来看会发现它带有时代的印记。就像我们所有人一样，我回看自己以前的代码也会想，我当时到底在想什么，我真不该那样写。从某种意义上说，那次演讲没问题，因为整个演讲的基础就是“这真的很有趣，也是一种很好的思考方式，但千万别写这种代码”。我从那次演讲中截取并放到我好几次演讲中的一句名言是：在某个阶段，你会去做这样一个练习，看看自己究竟能用 std accumulate 或某种类似 std accumulate 的柏拉图式等价物实现多少种算法，是的，没错，然后其中有百分之七十七的
the 90 of them right right and i think we had 90 algorithms in 14 something like that connor what just like yeah you just cut out one sec one sec connor is experiencing undefined behavior right now yes come back to us connor are you good can people can people hear me yeah we could hear you throughout the entire ordeal i'm guessing the listener can also hear you i in the middle of me saying the 77 of the 90 algorithms are implementable in terms of accumulate this woman started talking in my headphones saying your headphones are out of battery please recharge turning off okay see but i feel i feel like that was probably not the first warning that you got that your headphones were low on battery because that's true that's true that lady said something
90个里面占了90%，对吧。康纳，等等，就在刚才，康纳正在经历未定义行为，是的，康纳，回到我们身边来，你还好吗？大家能听到我说话吗？是的，我们在整个过程中都能听到你说话，我猜听众也能听到。就在我正说着 77% 的 90 个算法可以用 accumulate 实现时，我耳机里的那个女声开始说话了：“您的耳机电量不足，请重新充电，即将关闭。”好吧，但我感觉这大概不是你收到的关于耳机电量低的第一个警告，因为确实如此，确实如此，那个女士说了一些话
earlier today and i ignored her um yeah you should have listened all right ben back to you you were going to say one of your talks one of my talks that had quite a bit of impact and people still seem to remember, or at least, let's say, folks outside of the rarefied bubble of conference speakers that I talk to sort of in the real world and or in the games industry as I was in, they really enjoyed the um using types effectively talk that i gave
我想那是 CppCon 16 吧。那是你有那个……你知道我有多少类型的那个游戏吗？是的，一个小类型理论游戏……谈论类型，其特征是它们所持有的值的集合的基数。你今年要来 C++ Now 吗，Ben？是的，我会去的。那就在……不到两周后了，对吧？对，对。等这期节目播出时，今天是几号？是 19 号。事实上，我们录制这个的原因之一是因为我将要去 C++ Now，或者我们现在录制这个的原因之一是因为我要离开两周，在五月的前两周，并且……并且 Connor 需要所有的 Bryce 黄金来制作播客。也许我最后会单干。我们从来没有做过一期……
i think it was cppcon 16 is that the one where you have the you know how many types i have a little game yeah a little type theory game um talking about sites uh types as characterized by the cardinality of the set of values they hold are you are you coming to c++ now this year ben yep yes i'll be there that's in just over that's in less than two weeks now right yeah yeah by the time this airs what day is it it's the 19th in fact one of the reasons that we're recording this is because i will be at c++ now and or the one of the reasons we're recording this now is because i'm going to be gone for the first two weeks of may and uh and connor needs all the bryce gold to produce to produce the podcast maybe i'll just end up going solo we've never we've never done an episode where we
我想那是 2006 年的 CppCon 吗？是不是你在那儿玩那个你知道的“我有几种类型”的小游戏？一个关于类型理论的小游戏，谈到类型时，它们可以用其所持有一组值的基数来表征。本，你今年会去 C++ Now 吗？是的，我会去的。那是在两周多以后，不对，现在离那不到两周了，对吧？是的，等这期节目播出的那天是几号？19号。事实上，我们录制这期节目的原因之一是因为我要去 C++ Now，或者说我们现在录制这期节目的原因是我在五月份的前两周要离开，而康纳需要所有的布莱斯·戈尔德（Bryce Gold）来制作播客。也许我最后会选择单干，我们从来没有录制过一集是由
no no that's not true we had the one one episode, right? At C++ Now last year. Right. There was one episode without me. Connor and Tony and I. Yeah. It was Ben and I for the first bit, and then Canadians have a habit of showing up halfway into the recordings. That's not foreshadowing.
不，不对。我们有过一期节目，对吧？去年在 C++ Now 上。对。有一期没有我。Connor、Tony 和我。是的。前半部分是 Ben 和我，然后加拿大人有一种习惯，会在录音进行到一半时出现。这不是伏笔。
There's no random Canadian showing up today. So how this goes is I listen to your podcast probably every other week. And I catch up. And then invariably, it's like on a Saturday morning when I have some time. And then invariably, I DM Connor on Twitter. I only use Twitter for DMs these days. But I DM Connor and I say, I have opinions. This is true.
今天没有随机出现的加拿大人。所以情况是这样的：我大概每隔一周听一次你们的播客。我赶上进度。然后无一例外，那是在周六早上，当我有点时间的时候。然后无一例外，我会在 Twitter 上私信 Connor。我这些天只用 Twitter 发私信。但我私信 Connor 说：“我有意见。”这是真的。
And this is why Ben, so Ben, so this is uh gonna be i think i'm not sure if it's a response to multiple podcasts but ben dm'd me after the c++ algorithm family feud interview question uh of which oh i should i should call out we've got we've had like two or three people who have coded yeah two people one of, two people. One of them was from the C++ North Denver meetup, because I believe Tyler Oh, right. What was it? I want to get the name correct here. Tyler Weaver
这就是为什么 Ben，所以 Ben，所以这将会是……我觉得我不确定这是否是对多个播客的回应，但 Ben 在 C++ 算法家庭调查面试问题之后给我发了私信。顺便说一句，我应该提一下，我们有大约两到三个人编写了代码。对，两个人。其中一个人来自 C++ North Denver 聚会，因为我相信 Tyler……对。是什么来着？我想在这里把名字弄对。泰勒·韦弗（Tyler Weaver）
made both a YouTube video and sort of a Godbolt and a QuickBench and was basically saying that it looked like the max element where removing an element and then just doing another max element was the fastest and transform reduce was like the slowest i wasn't that ridiculous max element thing my idea yeah but we said it was a bad idea though hey hey hey hey i sir i sir i'm an architect now. My job is not to write code or to have good ideas.
制作了一个 YouTube 视频，还有 Godbolt 和 QuickBench，基本上是说看起来 `max_element` 删除了一个元素然后再次做 `max_element` 是最快的，而 `transform_reduce` 是最慢的。我指的不是那个荒谬的 `max_element` 东西，是我的主意。但我们说过那是个坏主意，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿！先生，我、我，我现在是一名架构师。我的工作不是写代码或有好主意。
My job is just to come up with ideas, and somebody else figures out if they're good or not. It's, yeah. So we'll get back to this. But anyways, Tyler Weaver had a YouTube video, and there was another individual. I'll grab his name at some point. So Ben DMed me after listening to this and said,
我的工作只是想出点子，然后由别人去搞清楚它们是不是好主意。是的。所以我们待会儿会回到这个话题。不管怎样，Tyler Weaver 有一个 YouTube 视频，还有另一个人。我稍后会查到他的名字。所以 Ben 听了之后给我发了私信说：
we need to chat. And I said, do you want to come on the podcast and he said yeah sure it doesn't matter to me as long as we get to chat and so we need to have we need to talk we need to have conversation well this is it like I have opinions right yeah who is it that messed up the worst was it me or was it Bryce no one messed up and i actually really enjoyed the format where like the game show format where you're like you're like okay bryce now name name the answer oh but name the series of answers in reverse order so when you pose the question which was uh find the top two right or the or the minimum two or the maximum two, same thing, right, in an unsorted array of integers, let's say. My immediate thought was nth element.
我们需要聊聊。我说：你想上播客吗？他说：行啊，对我来说无所谓，只要能聊就行。所以我们需要有……我们需要谈谈，我们需要进行对话。好吧，就是这样——就像我有意见一样，对吧？是的。是谁把事情搞得最糟？是我还是 Bryce？没人搞砸，我其实真的很喜欢这种形式，就像游戏节目形式一样，你会说：“好吧，Bryce，现在说出答案。哦，但要以相反的顺序说出一系列答案。”所以当你提出那个问题时，也就是在无序整数数组中寻找前两名（top two），或者说最小的两名或最大的两名，是一样的，对吧？我的第一反应是 `nth_element`。
That's what nth element does. But then, of course, as is your won't, you solved it with some reduction. And that's fine. Of course. This is the reduction yeah yeah yeah yeah so so it kind of is i still believe the correct name for that algorithm is top two or top n perhaps i mean i'm not claiming the nth element is particularly a good name for that application so it occurred to me like you you're interviewing probably for library developers, right?
这就是 `nth_element` 的作用。但当然，正如你所习惯的那样，你用某种 reduction（归约）来解决它。这很好。当然。这就是 reduction，对吧？所以……所以它有点……我仍然认为该算法的正确名称是 `top_two` 或 `top_n` 也许吧。我的意思是，我并不是说 `nth_element` 对于该应用来说是一个特别好的名字。所以我觉得，你面试的可能主要是库开发者，对吧？
As opposed to application developers. And there's a difference there. That's right. Because in an application developer, the obvious thing is, well, nth element, right? In a library developer, what I would like as an application developer is for nth element to be implemented with a reduction under the hood. If that is faster, taking into account array size, parallelism, element size, that sort of thing. You made a comment to that effect yourself, Bryce, where you said something about like the, you know, the performance may vary depending on several of those things anyway. Yeah.
而不是应用程序开发者。这里面有区别。没错。因为对于应用程序开发者来说，显而易见的事情就是，嗯，`nth_element`，对吧？对于库开发者来说，作为一个应用程序开发者，我希望 `nth_element` 在底层是用 reduction 来实现的。如果这样更快的话，考虑到数组大小、并行性、元素大小诸如此类的事情。你自己也对此发表了评论，Bryce，你说了一些类似……你知道的，性能可能会根据其中几个因素而有所不同。是的。
So one of the things I think is a good part of this question, and as you said before, I don't ask technical questions in interviews. But if I was, and I was going to use this question. Look at Bryce trying not to say, oh, this was a good question. Actually, let me correct myself. It's in a bad category of questions that I don't endorse. But in that bad category, it's an okay question. It's more I call into question the entire notion of how traditional tech interviews are conducted. But that aside, if I'm looking for a library developer, I'm looking for somebody who looks at this question, comes up with multiple different answers.
所以我觉得这个问题的优点之一是，正如你之前所说，我在面试中不问技术问题。但如果我要问，而且我要用这个问题……看 Bryce 努力不去说“哦，这是一个好问题”。其实，让我纠正自己。它属于那种我不赞同的不良问题类别。但在那个不良类别中，它是一个尚可的问题。我更多地是质疑传统技术面试的整个进行方式。但除此之外，如果我在寻找库开发者，我在寻找这样一个人：他看到这个问题，能给出多种不同的答案。
And then like the really the right way to answer this question is to tell me that there is no one correct answer. That here are the options and that there are going to be different circumstances under which these will be, you know, each one of these will be the right one. And that like maybe the way that you would build a high performance implementation, a generic implementation of this would be to use a combination of different strategies. Yeah. Yeah. Because, I mean, as a very specific question, top two. Great. The generalization is top N, of course, which in some sense is nth element. Yes. And that's where it's like, well, top two, you know, like a pair is very easy, a very small amount of data, assuming you have a small element size. But if you want top a thousand, like that might be a very different sort of problem that parallelization might not be amenable to. And in general, median is a problem that's annoyingly hard to parallelize, I think.
然后，真正正确回答这个问题的方法是告诉我，没有一个唯一的正确答案。这里有不同的选择，在不同的情况下，这些选择（你知道的，每一个）都会是正确的。而且，也许你构建高性能实现、通用实现的方式，是使用不同策略的组合。是的。是的。因为，我的意思是，作为一个非常具体的问题，`top_two`。很好。泛化就是 `top_n`，当然，在某种意义上就是 `nth_element`。是的。这就是为什么会觉得，嗯，`top_two`，你知道的，就像一个 pair（对）非常简单，数据量非常小，假设你的元素大小很小。但如果你想要 `top_a_thousand`（前一千名），那可能是非常不同的一种问题，并行化可能并不适用。而且总的来说，我认为中位数（median）是一个令人讨厌的难以并行化的难题。
It's definitely not one of the trivial bread and butter, like a reduction, the bread and butter one. Yeah. So that's interesting. I guess my first thought is how many algorithms, like the first one I can think of is, I think the std sort has the behavior where depending on the size, it will choose different sort algorithms. And I think like the actual name of, I'm not sure if it's the same across
它绝对不是那种微不足道的、基本的面包和黄油般的东西，比如 reduction 那种基本的。是的。所以这很有趣。我猜我的第一个想法是有多少算法……我能想到的第一个算法是，我认为 `std::sort` 的行为是，根据大小，它会选择不同的排序算法。而且我认为……其实名字是什么……我不确定它在 `libstdc++` 和 `libc++` 中是否相同，但我认为至少其中一个使用了 introsort（内省排序），这就像是归并排序（merge sort）和……我不会把另一个弄错，但就像快速排序（quicksort）之类的一样，当超过一定大小时，它选择归并排序，但一旦降到一定大小以下，它就会切换到另一个。
libstd C++ and libc++, but I think at least one of them uses introsort, which is like a combination of merge sort and I'm not going to get the other one wrong, but like quicksort or something like that where above a certain size, it chooses merge sort, but then once it gets down below a certain size, it then switches to another one.
这实际上……Python 中也有类似的东西，它们某种混合算法，是以某个人名命名的。所以你知道算法头文件中实际有多少算法具有这种行为吗？所以这基本上就是我们……你在这里争论的是，它应该是使用 `nth_element` 的 `top_n`，用于平均情况下表现良好的情况，然后它切换到一个简单 reduction，它只有……等等，等等。我想我会争论说 `top_n` 实际上就是 `nth_element`。我认为真正的问题是，`nth_element` 的实现是否应该对两个元素的情况，或者一、二、三个元素的情况进行特殊处理（special case）？事实上，做一个实验看看分界点在哪里、什么时候进行特殊处理是有意义的，这将是一件很有趣的事情。
And that's actually, it's something similar in Python that they have some kind of hybrid algorithm and it's named after some individual. So do you know how many algorithms actually in the algorithm header have behavior like that? So that's basically what we're, you're arguing here is it should be top N that uses nth element for the cases that on average it's good for, and then it switches to a simple reduction that just has... Hang on, hang on. I think I would argue that the top end really is just nth element. I think really the question is, should nth element implementations special case the case of two elements, or the case of one, two, and three elements? And actually, it would be an interesting experiment to see what the cutoff point is, which it makes sense to special case this.
我的另一个观察是，我认为 reduction 是……你可以纠正我，但我认为它必然会返回给你一个有序对（ordered pair）。它的实现方式必须是这样的。而 `nth_element`，当然，不一定对前几名排序。是的，好吧，这取决于……比如在并行版本中，如果你有关联（associative）和交换（commutative）操作，它实际上会是这样的。但我认为语义……是的，我认为对 pair 进行 reduction 的语义意味着你必须指定一个作为较高者，一个作为较低者，否则你必须……是的。但为什么……为什么 `nth_element` 不能给你……给你顺序呢？`nth_element` 不必排序，因为它没有完全排序。它最终可能会对一个 pair 排序，我不太清楚，但如果你向它请求 `top_n`，它会锁定第 n 个元素。
The other observation I had is I think the reduction is, you can correct me on this, but I think it's by necessity giving you back the ordered pair. The way it would have to be implemented. Whereas nth element, of course course doesn't order the top yep necessarily well it depends so like in the parallel version where you have the associative the associative and commutative operation it actually will be but i think the semantic yeah i think the semantics of reducing the pair mean that you have to designate one as the higher and one is the lower otherwise you'd have to you yeah but why wouldn't why wouldn't the nth element give you give you the order nth element doesn't have to order because it's not sorted it might end up ordering a pair i don't exactly know but if you ask you ask it for top end, it's going to pin the nth element.
它上面的所有东西都会排在它上面，但不一定按正确的顺序。所以 `nth_element` 的 API 是三个迭代器：范围的开头，你想要放在正确位置的元素，以及范围的末尾。你唯一能保证的是，在你指定的那个点——你的 `nth_element` 点——以下的所有东西都小于（或者如果你使用默认比较器的话），然后它以上的所有东西都更大，并且你保证那个点就是它在排序中会出现的位置，如果它是有序的话，那将是一个局部排序（partial sort），对吧？完全正确。而且我认为 Kate Gregory 实际上在某个时候，
Everything above it is going to belong above it, but not necessarily in the right order. So the API for nth element is three iterators, the beginning of the range, the element that you want to get at the right spot and then the end of the range and the only thing you're guaranteed is that everything below that point your nth element point is less than or whatever if you're using the default comparator and then everything above it is greater and then you're guaranteed that at that point is where it would show up in a sort of if it were ordered that would be a partial sort, right? Exactly. And I think Kate Gregory actually at one point,
她在她的一个演讲中说 `partial_sort_copy` 应该被称为 `top_n`。然后在随后的一个演讲中，我指出实际上 `partial_sort_copy` 应该被称为 `top_n_sorted`，而 `nth_element_copy` 应该被称为 `top_n`。因为 partial sort 那个是保证你的 top n 会被排序的……但是如果……如果你使用 `nth_element` 来做 `top_two`，难道不是恰好……它就会是有序的吗，仅仅针对 `top_two` 这种情况？是的。哦，是的，其实这是一个好点子。但……我想重点是它没有做任何额外的比较来让情况变成那样，对吧？我只是……我只是意味着，在两个元素的情况下，它确实碰巧变成了……是的，我的意思是，也许……我不认为我们需要一个 `top_n` 或 `nth_element`。我认为实际上你要么使用 `nth_element`，要么使用 `partial_sort_copy`，这取决于你是否想要它们有序。但对于其中一些较低计数的情况进行特殊处理的问题是一个有趣的问题。我们在 CUB 库中最终做的许多优化——这是我们的算法原语库，CUDA 的并行算法原语库——我们获得的许多重大性能提升是因为……就像我们识别了一个特殊情况，你知道的，这碰巧很容易优化，而且很多人恰好会落入其中。所以几乎每个算法都有某种决策树，你知道的，如果是这种情况，你就这样做，否则你就那样做。`nth_element` 之所以有趣还有另一个原因。我长期以来一直认为它是某种最被冷落的算法，或者说最被忽视的算法。正如你所知，在……我想是 17 标准中，sort 的复杂度界限被收紧了。在 17 之前，它曾说……我想是 17 吧？也许是 14 甚至 11。也许是 11。
she in one of her talks says that partial sort copy should be called top end. And then in a talk that I later gave, I pointed out that actually partial sort copy should be called top end sorted and nth element copy should be called top end because the partial sort one is the one that guarantees that your your top n are going to be sorted but but if the if the k if you're using nth element to do top two doesn't it happen to be the case that that it'll be in order just for that case of top two yes oh yeah actually that's a good point but but i guess the point is it hasn't done any extra
她在其中一次演讲中提到，partial sort copy 应该被称为 top end。而在我后来的一次演讲中，我指出实际上 partial sort copy 应该被称为 top end sorted，而 nth element copy 应该被称为 top end，因为 partial sort 能够保证你的前 n 个元素是有序的。但是，如果你用 nth element 来获取前两个元素，难道不是刚好在这种获取前两个元素的情况下，它们也是有序的吗？是的，哦，对，实际上这确实是个好点子。但我想重点是，它并没有做任何额外的
comparisons to make that the case right i just i just meant that like yeah in the case of two it like it does sort of happen to be um yeah i mean maybe maybe case i don't i don't think that we need a top in our element i think that the thatend element. I think that really it's just you either use nth element or you use partial sort copy, depending on whether you want them ordered or not. But this question of special casing for some of these lower count cases is an interesting one. A lot of the optimizations that we end up doing in the CUB library, which is our library of algorithmic primitives, of parallel algorithmic primitives for CUDA. A lot of the big performance wins that we get is because like we identify a special case that, you know, happens to be easy to optimize and also like a lot of people just
但它过去说的是平均 `n log n`。而现在标准规定 sort 就是 `n log n`，句号。对吧？我想我们在 17 中清理了这一点，因为我们在添加并行算法时清理了许多复杂度，我们不得不弄清楚它们的复杂度，但我可能记错了。对 `nth_element` 没有进行同样的清理。`nth_element` 平均是线性的。但我认为基本上同样的工作——也就是 Dave Musser 的工作，他在 2000 年代做了大量这方面的工作，我想是那时，这引领了 Connor 谈到的 introsort，以及使 sort 在平均情况下达到 `n log n` 的可能性——我认为同样的基础……
fall into it. So almost every algorithm has some decision tree of, you know, if it's this case, you do this thing and otherwise you do this thing. The element is interesting for another reason. It's I have long considered it the sort of most unloved algorithm or most overlooked algorithm. And as you know, in I think it was 17, the complexity boundaries of sort were tightened. It used to say prior to seven, I think it's 17, right? Maybe 14 or even 11. Maybe it was 11.
同样的基础工作转化为如果我们想要的话，让 `nth_element` 在句号意义上是线性的。总得有人写篇论文。外面的听众，如果你有兴趣参与标准委员会的工作，是的。因为 introselect 是 `nth_element` 的算法对应物，就像 introsort 一样，对吧？对，是的。这部分是一场可能分为四部分的算法系列的第 1 部分。感谢收听，我们希望你喜欢并度过美好的一天。本集尚无评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可发表评论。
But it used to say n log n on average. And now the standard says sort is n log n, period. Right? I think we cleaned that up in 17 because we cleaned up a lot of the complexities when we added the parallel algorithms and we had to figure out the complexities for them, but I could be wrong. The same cleanup was not done for nth element. Nth element is linear on average. But I think essentially the same work, which is the work of Dave Musser, he did a lot of work on this back in the 2000s, I think it was, that led to intro sort that Connor was talking about and the possibility of making sort n log n on average i think that same underlying
但它以前说的是平均复杂度为 $n \log n$。而现在标准规定 sort 的复杂度就是 $n \log n$，句号。对吧？我想我们在 C++17 中清理了这一点，因为我们在添加并行算法时清理了许多复杂度说明，并且我们必须弄清楚它们的复杂度，不过我可能记错了。nth element 没有进行同样的清理。nth element 的平均复杂度是线性的。但我认为，本质上是同一项工作——即戴夫·穆瑟（Dave Musser）的工作，他在 2000 年代左右在这方面做了大量工作（我想是的）——促成了康纳刚才谈到的内省排序（intro sort），并使 sort 的平均复杂度达到 $n \log n$ 成为可能。我认为同样的基础
that same underlying work translates to making nth element linear period if we wanted that someone's got to write a paper listener out there if you're interested in getting involved in standard committee work yeah because intro select is the algorithm counterpart to for enthousiasm for intro sort right right yeah this ends part one of what will probably be a four-part series on algorithms thanks for listening we hope you enjoy and have a great day There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
同样的基础工作如果转换一下，也可以让 nth element 的复杂度在任何情况下都变成线性的，只要我们想这么做的话。得有人写篇论文才行。听众朋友们，如果你有兴趣参与标准委员会的工作……是的，因为 intro select 就是 intro sort 在 nth element 算法上的对应版本，对吧？对，没错。至此，这期关于算法的系列节目（大概会分为四部分）的第一部分就结束了。感谢收听，希望你们喜欢，祝大家有个美好的一天。本集节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。